pour soir c'est une véritable marée
humaine qui déferle qui défilent en ce
moment même dans les rues de paris c'est
le gros de la troupe est arrivée sur la
pelouse de reuilly la marche gay
lesbienne n'est toujours pas terminée vu
le nombre de participants 270 mille
personnes selon les organisateurs venus
de l'europe entière le reportage de
caroline douillet et de xavier colombier
europride ça veut dire pierrick de se
montrer s'assumer que l'on aime et qui
on est les gays et lesbiennes étaient
300 milles cet après-midi dans les rues
de paris et se sentait bien ensemble
dans la foule européenne cette année
beaucoup envient les scandinaves
exemplaire car seul pays au monde à
avoir légalisé le mariage civil entre
mots et donner les mêmes droits sociaux
et juridiques à tous à mme julie
ouvertement de son homosexualité au
travail j'ai des amis hétéros et homos
une vie tout à fait normale en somme
c'est la vieille tradition libérale des
scandinaves en faites vous
et les suisses ils n'en pensent quoi
regarder les français eux sont plutôt
optimistes le contrat d'union civile
s'annonce bien les politiques présents
ont rappelé leur détermination
j'ai une idée de ma détermination et de
celle de quelques responsables notamment
parmi les députés socialistes donc nous
déterminer nous ferons aboutir ce texte
plus vite possible mais pour l'instant
il reste encore les points noirs le
désir d'enfant l'adoption impossible les
droits sociaux il faut l'héritage dans
le couple toujours pas reconnu
quand on change de boulot par exemple
quand on arrive en nouvelle ambiance on
est toujours obligé de se justifier ou
trois bd tour des contours et s'alliant
à oyonnax un parent dont les maisons de
retraite ouverte à tous
quand on connaît la différence de
certains vieux on leur fait une vie
triste
on a vu à que l'homicide il reste les
pires qui n'osent pas facilement la
visibilité et tous ceux qui ne voient
encore les homos que comme des folles ou
des drag queens
mais les mentalités évoluent les hétéros
était là aussi en soutien pour avoir
conscience que demain nos enfants
peuvent être homosexuel d'entre eux déjà
accepté au départ
l'espoir d'être un jour tout à fait
comme tout le monde est en marche
ce soir et toute la nuit ce sera la fête
sur la pelouse de reuilly et lourd